hosts Germany underscored its support
for the Ukrainian opposition
anti-government protesters have been in
the streets of Kiev for months calling
for President Viktor Yanukovych to quit
desert we say to President Yanukovych
and his people that they must now
completely and comprehensively fulfill
the promises he's made to the opposition
the United States has also backed the
opposition and has steadily ramped up
pressure on the government to give in to
opposition demands that means their
futures do not have to lie with one
country alone and certainly not coerced
the United States and EU stand with the
people of Ukraine in that fight that's a
message Kerry reiterated in meetings
with top Ukrainian opposition leaders
Ukraine's allied to the East Russia
accused the west of bias in favor of the
opposition Foreign Minister Sergei
Lavrov accused Western governments of
double standards you British or la
Prosser why don't we condemn those who
seize and hold government buildings
attack the police he's racist
anti-semitic and Nazi slogans bad boxing
champion turned opposition leader Vitali
Klitschko said the ukrainian President
was the main obstacle Klitschko said
that there was just one person
responsible for the escalation and that
person could easily stop it he was
speaking of ukrainian President Viktor
Yanukovych saying he had absolute power
in his hands and absolute responsibility
for what happened in the Ukraine earlier
Klitschko joined a protest march in
munich by hundreds of exiled Ukrainians
he expressed his confidence the
opposition would eventually get its way